i was invited to dj at a ski party and i
saw my friends do this thing up close
and personal and i thought it was the
coolest thing i'd ever seen my friends
literally turning into superheroes right
there in front of my eyes and i vowed
that i wanted to be able to do this this
sport with them and so two months later
uh in february of 2016 i had my first
lesson in whistler in canada
okay um how likely are you to get a
medal
zero zero chance um i mean look the
international olympic committee sets out
as standard which is a minimum threshold
of competence and uh safety we are
nowhere near those guys that have been
doing this since the age of two and have
had like millions of dollars poured into
their advancement over the last 10 or 15
years they're they're in a different
league
uh looking at um some uh images of you
definitely look the part all the gear
certainly haven't you um how much do you
enjoy it how much does it change your
life
oh it's the best thing i absolutely love
being out in the mountains look at
jackson hole in that photo there i mean
look how beautiful that is it's
absolutely incredible to be out in the
mountains exercising waking up with the
sun or even before the sun on most days
and just being active it's a complete
shift from my life of being a vampire
living in nightclubs and going to
festivals and so i'm relishing this
change as i approach my uh my 40s
amazing are you worried about breaking
bones and things because you know let's
face it most of these olympic skiers
learn when they're two or three
yeah no there's no fear of breaking
bones at all i mean i'm i'm proficient
at skiing and that's why i qualified the
course is not going to be easy they're
probably going to be they're probably
going to be 90 athletes that are going
to go out there and beat the course up
before i get my chance to to go out
there but uh no i mean our skis are as
sharp as razor blades and i've cut my
hands on them a million times um but no
it's this is just like showing up at the
office
so you're representing jamaica in
beijing via north london tell us how
that works
yeah it's an interesting one i like to
consider myself a global citizen uh born
in england uh to a jamaican father and
an english mother left england in 2006
and have basically lived all over the
world for the last 16 years
what's the camaraderie like um in the
team i think you're only the 15th
jamaican to represent your country at
the winter olympics
yeah i haven't had the chance to meet up
with the bob said guys and girl just yet
we interact a lot on social media and
we're all super excited to get out there
and do this thing for our country so i
can't wait to meet them i've already
been sent all of the gear as you can see
i'm proudly wearing this i haven't taken
it off in the last three days um and i
think it's just gonna be a lot of fun
when we get out there for me personally
there's no
pressure to perform as i said for me
it's about setting the foundations and
building the framework for jamaica to
have a really strong ski team in in
olympics to come um so i'm just gonna
have fun out there
what's with the teddies
you know when you get all of these calls
when you're moving around the world you
have to choose the quietest room and
right now it's the teddy bear so i've
got some company with me on sky news
when do you head out to beijing
24 hours i'll be out there uh flying
through zurich uh and i'll be there on
the ground by wednesday
okay will you talk to us while you're
out there tell us how you've got on
yeah absolutely would love to
okay look forward to it thank you so
much good luck
thank you thank you so much thanks a lot
bye